تعرف العالم على نيكول مانسفيلد بعدما قام
التلفزيون السوري بعرض بطاقه رخصه القياده
الخاصه بها وصور لسياره تم الهجوم عليها
وبداخلها جثتها ابنه نيكول تريانا جونز
تعيش في متشيغان وتبلغ من العمر 18 عاما
ولكنها لا يمكنها استيعاب ما حدث لوالدتها
تقول تريانا انها تحدثت مع والدتها منذ
بضعه اسابيع ولم تكن تعرف مكانها ولكنها
كانت على علم بانها ارادت الذهاب الى
سوريا تقديم
المساعده نيكول كانت تفضل عدم الخوض في
معتقداتها الدينيه امام افراد عائلتها
لتجنب اي خلاف محتمل معهم وتقول عائله
مانسفيلد انها اعتنقت الاسلام منذ ما يقرب
من خمس سنوات وكانت تواظب على الصلاه في
المسجد هنا اما والد نيكول فقد اعترض على
اعتناق ابنته للاسلام وانتاب القلق عندما
سافرت الى دبي في السنوات
الاخيره
وقد ابلغ المباحث الفيدراليه ببواعث قلقه
ووعد الاف بي اي بمتابعه الموضوع ولم يقدم
اف بي اي ايه اجابات ليبقى موت نيكول في
سوريا
غامضا